[Music]
I'm Billy Mitchell video game player of
the century I did the world's first
perfect score on pac-man 3 million
333366 Austin - just say I began in the
competitive world of pinball it moved to
Donkey Kong
but the greatest level of competition at
the moment was pac-man if I was going to
be the best I had to be the best at the
game that was everywhere so in 1999 I
sent out a press release I was as cocky
as could be they said there's been 10
billion games played how are you going
to do it I says because I'm Billy
Mitchell you start off on the first
board but on board 21 that's where it's
reaches maximum difficulty you have to
navigate all the way towards 255 doing
the same repetitive thing you can't miss
it off a prize a blue man
you can't die once you can please focus
you got to stay with it all away there
four to five hours you have to take a
corner down to one sixtieth of a second
in order to create perfect timing and
keep your eye right here right here
you have to do that over 29,000 times
without making the mistakes of diet you
play 255 boards on 256 there's enough
memory left in the game for the left
half of the board and not the right half
the right half is filled with computer
garble anything and everything that is
not packed in different walls different
dots that's what a perfect score is the
moment that score went up there I
thought wow I achieved perfection you
get to the end there's nothing to do but
die there was nothing saying
congratulations
there was nothing saying the end game
over nothing the designer of pac-man not
only did he never think anyone would get
to the end he didn't know where the end
was he didn't know what point the game
would run out of memory everything to
him is completely baffling they never
saw the split screen until I sent it to
them
Masaya Nakamura who's the godfather of
video games he crowned me video game
player of the century for that and all
the previous achievements it doesn't get
any higher than that
[Music]
[Music]
it's cool to go back to those games that
were so brutally hard as a kid where I
couldn't even beat the first level and
learn how to absolutely destroy the
games
it took me very very long time to even
be able to beat Super Mario Brothers for
instance and now I have the record of it
[Music]
you may know me as darbian on Twitch
my name is Brad and I'm the world record
holder in Super Mario Brothers so the
goal of speedrunning is what the goal of
speedrunning is to go fast
it took me six thousand six hundred and
seven tries to set the record I can feel
my heart going kind of crazy in my chest
I get a little uncomfortable
I might notice my hands sweating more
I'll get antsy I'll hit a button too
early or too late or I'll try to play
too perfectly because I say I may never
get another opportunity like this I
better not blow it let's go all out I
think you need to be a very patient
person to speedrun as you come closer
and closer to reaching the goal like you
get later later in the particular run
these thoughts start going through your
head could this be it I hope I don't
screw this up the neat thing about
speedrunning is that the expected
outcome is failure and the better you
get at it the more you fail that was the
game there that's like 30 seconds off of
the directory
[Music]
it was the game that coined a dozen
catchphrases and made over a billion
dollars from quarters maybe a jam almost
never saw the light of day
[Music]
this is NBA Jam game designer mark
Turmel so we put together a demo
videotape VHS we sent it to the NBA and
said hey we're making this cool game and
they immediately shut it down and said
no we don't want the NBA logo in the
arcades so once we got rejected we made
a video tape of nice family
entertainment centers and we sent that
back to them and said look you know this
year logo can be here so they relented
and provided the license when we put it
in the arcade for the very first time
there were no stats that differentiated
the players everybody assumed that Shaq
was a bad 3-point shooter or Stockton
could steal the ball so we realized
pretty quickly that we had to you know
up our game to match the real world well
if it's just looking at pure attributes
I happen to be the best player in the
game when you actually put in my secret
character it just shows question marks
for the stats but they're all tens or
nine
I'm pretty good at innovation to test
the claim we have mark hack into the
machine where we go and turn on cheat
codes right now we're talking usually
when somebody finds out that I've made
NBA Jam they say I spent so much money
on that NBA Jam or you know I flunked a
class in college because of NBA Jam well
I look at the game now
I wish it were smoother but it was the
technology at the time the game still
holds up today
[Music]
it's a time-honored thing to put your
name on your artistic productions
writers have their name on the book
painters write their name in the corner
why couldn't videogame designers have
their name in their games this is a
story about one man who took out a giant
tech company and change the gaming world
in the process
[Music]
my name is Warren Robinett I'm the
creator of adventure
the first action adventure game this was
a video game that I wrote working for
Atari in the late 70s they treated us
badly in several different ways no
royalties no name on the box no external
recognition being told that we were
easily replaceable they disrespected us
so Ward hatched the perfect plan what I
did was I hid my name in the game in a
secret room that was really hard to get
to when he got in there the screen
filled up with flashing movie marquee
that said created by Warren Robinett
Atari shipped out 200,000 copies of
adventure before anyone discovered
Warren's secret room how did they find
out about that 15 year old boy in Salt
Lake City wrote a letter to Atari and he
very clearly explained how to get into
the secret room and Warren wasn't
worried at all about repercussions what
are they gonna do take away my royalty
well they weren't giving us any
royalties fire me so happened that I'd
already quit but to warden surprise his
act of rebellion was well received by
Ataris new lead game designer Steve
Wright
he's musing to himself about this
situation and he said it was kind of
cool to have hidden surprises and video
games it's like waking up on Easter
morning and going out and finding
colored Easter eggs under the bushes and
flowers everything ended all right for
Warren Robinett you can't say the same
for Atari Atari actually collapsed in
one year it imploded personally I think
there's some poetic justice there that
the big powerful rich New York pushy
guys could not defeat the one little 26
year old programmer who just had a
sneaky idea and pulled it off without
telling anybody
[Music]
Tetris it transcends age culture and
language it's a gamer and non-gamers
game but did you know Tetris has a
Soviet past Tetris is the brainchild of
this man Alexey Pajitnov
Alexey was a computer programmer in
Russia he worked for the Soviet Union at
the Moscow Academy of Sciences Alexey
always had a propensity for math
computers and puzzles it was that
propensity that led him to the creation
of the best video game of all time he
drew inspiration from a little-known
game pentominoes pentominoes was a
puzzle board game in which you had to
fit geometric shapes together Alexey
took the principles from pentominoes
upgraded them and created a computer
game originally only intended for
himself he named the game Tetris for two
reasons it's a combination of tetra the
Greek word meaning for and tennis [ __ ]
na favorite sport because Tetris was
created during work hours the Soviet
Union claimed all rights to both Tetris
and all royalties boy fast forward to
1996 the rights of tetris was finally
signed over to posit enough tetris taps
into our universal need to create order
out of chaos which is ultimately why
it's one of the most iconic games in
history
you
[Music]